all right 6 25 on your friday morning
what's driving you crazy well how about
the big picture
and the minute details where the 95
meets the northern 215 beltway come on
along let's go
centennial bowling
so as we await next month's completion
of the last big flyover ramp there the
one that's going to take you from the
south 95 to the east 215 we have the big
umbrella picture of what all that work
in the centennial bowl's been about
and that's talking about improved travel
time reliability adding lanes hov ramps
improved connectivity
they're saying travel times are going to
become more reliable then they talk
about
aesthetics here's what they say the
commuter experience is enhanced with
community driven aesthetic plans
to beautify the corridor hopefully
you've noticed now as for the details
here's one that i think has been
overlooked with all the concrete there
they're also talking about building
a multi-use bike and pedestrian trail
this is going to be around centennial
parkway
and sky point drive so ndot's centennial
bowl website has all of this info and a
ton
more and we've got the link to nevada
us95nw.com on our website which is a lot
easier to remember
eight newsnow.com you click traffic then
driving you crazy buckle up drive
carefully please put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com